oh hi on today's episode of game life
I'd like to talk about Square Enix there
recently getting into iOS games in a big
way in fact they've just released two
major game's final fantasy dimensions
and demons score but both these games
have in common is while they're both a
very high quality one is a role-playing
game what is a music game but they also
have in common is they both make
extensive use of in-app purchases for
extra content or in the case of these
games most of the game's content and I
don't really think they're doing it in
the right way final fantasy dimensions
is something that in theory Final
Fantasy fans have been asking for for a
long time it's a brand-new fully
featured role playing game modeled after
the 16-bit classics that defined the
early era of the series there's sprite
graphics chiptunes even the job changing
systems from final fantasy 5 final
fantasy dimensions is a free download
once you grab the app you can play
through the prologue which will
introduce you to the basics of the
battle system and take about an hour
once that's over you have to pay up or
else you can't play anymore you have to
pay three dollars for the game's first
chapter and then ten dollars each for
the next three chapters oh and if you
want that chiptune soundtrack that I
talked about instead of the normal
version another ten bucks so that's $43
for the fully featured game now yeah
that's why I pay for games on my 3ds but
they're way better than this one
dimensions is good for an iphone game
but it's not $43 good not only that it's
kind of hard to even make that
determination with a really really short
demo version demons score also has some
issues I was really excited for this for
good reason it's a music game by Ennis
the maker of some of my favorite music
games like guitar ooh man and elite beat
agents you play a girl fighting these
crazy demons and you cap on the screen
to the rhythm of the music it works
great the gameplays awesome the
characters are ridiculously stupid and
therefore very funny and
I mean what doesn't make a lot of sense
though is the in-app purchasing system
first you pay seven dollars for the game
now that's already kind of expensive for
an iphone game but it's reasonable
considering this is a high quality 3d
unreal engine product but you're not
even a few minutes into the game and
when it starts hitting you up for these
massive transactions once you clear the
second stage you're asked if you want to
pay three dollars to make a pact with a
demon but what does that mean well only
by making pacts with these demons can
you play different pieces of music so
unless you pay three dollars three
dollars three dollars three dollars for
each of the games eight levels you have
to play the same two songs over and over
and over itunes reviews are slamming
demon score over this they're calling it
a scam they're saying you're paying
seven dollars for a demo and it's a real
shame because it's a good game but the
in-app purchasing system it just doesn't
make any sense it makes people feel like
they're getting ripped off if you want
to do a good free to play game you've
got to hit people up for money after
they've been playing for a while after
they're addicted when they really don't
want to stop aggressively hitting them
up for big dollar amounts like three
dollars or ten dollars after they've
only played the game for a couple of
minutes it just doesn't work and it's
hurting really good games